Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to Bonbon!
Now Bonbon has absolutely dick diddly to do with Bonnie from Five Night's at Freddy's.
This is another horror game about something that I don't know.
But apparently you get a gift - and apparently I'm going to bed - but apparently you get a gift.
And that gift - I believe - is named Bonbon.
So a little bit like... Tattletail, in a way, I suppose..
But then, again, that's all my guess, so I don't actually know what's going on here.
Okay... Is that Bonbon? Should I be con-
Oh, am I- Oh- Oooh..
Ohh..
I'm a baby, I think. I'm pretty sure I'm a baby.
Oh.
Hi BonBon, how are you doin'?
Play with wh- "Play with Wobbly Dog"?
Ohh..
I have telekinetic powers, apparently.
"Give Wobbly Dog a big push"..
"Rotate Wobbly Dog"..
"Say, 'Hello Wobbly Dog!'"
H̷̢̛͓͔͎̤͇̤̣̘͔̪̹́́͊͋̽̈́̊̌̈ͅę̴͈̹̥͔͔̱̬̫̬̊̈́̾̍̒̇̂̇̇̈́̎͂̈́͜͝l̸̪̞̉̅̓ĺ̵̢̨̡̤̦̥͚̦̞̦̠̰̥͒̓̎̏́̍͋̇̐ǫ̸̈̓̓ ̸̡̼̫̟̘̱̗̞̞͍͕̼͇̥̑̂͒̎̀̎͛̍̋͠Ẅ̵̡͈͚̩͕̣̹͓͎͈͔̼͓́̈͒̋̎̔̾́̒͋̕̚͠o̸̧̝̭͍̲͍̫͇̝͋͝b̶̻̩̪̹͎̌̊̊́̿̅͐͑́͝͝b̷̳̘͕̲͎́̆̈́̈́̈́̀͘͘͘l̵̡̈́̓̿̄̍͂͒͌̅̑̓̓͝y̴̡̯̳̘̩͙͇̳͔̫͐̂͌̀̀͘͜ ̴̬̠̋D̵̩̿̄̐̒̊̀͐̓͌̈̅̈̆̌ơ̵̛̞̘͇̰͍͕̆̃̇ͅg̷̺̮̖̳͓͖̬̤͂̏̽̃̓̀̾̉͝!̶͍̬͖͍̒͊̀͂̽̊̔͊
... Whaat was that?
I'ma rotate Wobbly Dog..
Dat's a nice doggy..?
That's a good doggy.
Alright, I'm gonna give you a BIIIIG boosh..
Uh-oh.
Okay then?
I gave Wobbly Dog a big push..
Awh..
Oh.
"Carrying toys is hard work for little hands. Remember you can throw and push as well!"
Okey dokey, then..
Hah..
H̴̨̭̤͇͙̏̋̒̆̉̋̃̐̍͜͝͠ͅè̴̙̠̘̮̙͚͚̬̜̯̃̓́̿́͝ͅl̸̢͑̉l̴͉͈̩̽͛̀̀͜͝͠o̴̢͎͚͕̩͍̤̰͚͍̩̓͗͆̑͆̓ ̸̗͇͕̣̗͎͎̲̞̳͚͕̹͍͑̈́͗̂͌͂̊͝W̴̲͕̰̣̩͂́̋̄͐͒͑̃͒͛o̴̼̞͌̎̔̾̚͜b̴̢̛̭̼̣̀̈́͐̇̆͑̏̊̈́́̈́͗̚b̴̨̹̠̣̺͖̰̽͒̉̏̽̀̈̚l̴̫͙͎̈́̔̈͐͛͝͝y̷̛̛̳̟͎̠̍̿̂̑̄̐͌̌̃͒͠͝ͅ ̴̨̻̥̓̿̃̈̉̓͌̚̚͘̚͠͠D̸̨̛̖̤̞̩̮͎̫̹̲̺̓̌̈̓͊͆̏̚͘ờ̶͍̈̎̊̀̑̒̀͐͜g̵̯̯͕͔͉̠̝̔!̷̡̛͚̟̝̙͉͉̺̺͉̰̱͕͑̏̃̈̃̇̇̉̓͑̆͠͝͝
"Find all four balls and put them inside the house for Mummy."
I don't like this! [chuckles]
I got suspicions about this right now! Is this a ball?
Or just one of those bouncy... boingers?
Oh, Bouncy Hopper. Oh, it's close.
"Hello, Bouncy Hop..."
H̸̥̖͖̺̜͇̗̝̝̟͇̠̹͒̓͜͠ͅę̴̯͎͓̟̺͎̳̈̄̌̈́̎͐̈͘͝l̷̢̡̗̬͍͍̄̿̈̌͝l̷̨̨͚̝̤̦̥̣̮̖̻͓̥̻̽o̷̤̥̲͓͇͔̖͕̥͒̓͒͒̏̐̈́̌̕͘̕̕͜͝ͅ ̷̢̢̥͈̺͙̳͈͇̼̰͈̤̲̈̄̈́̆̈́̂̍̾̓̋́͐̕͜͝͠B̵̨̰̺͚͖̉̇̈́̋͗̈́̽̚͘͜͠ͅố̵̳͈̟͚͈̞͕̘̠̪̘̳͈͉̽ͅu̵̗͖͚̲̥̝͖̪͔͕̞͚̬̝͌̎̒̿̽̕͠ņ̶̙̣̰͚͍̼͓̘̙̪̑̆̀̋̈̚c̶͎̱̫͚͇͌̑̽̑͆̽̈́̈́͋́͑̓̕y̷̰̣̪̏̉̀̊̚͘͝ͅ ̸̧̧̢̡̣̞̖͉̗̰̬̼͖̦̮̊̒̆̀̋̎̂̈͂̕̚̚̕H̵̫͍̱̖̯̉̂͋̏̾͂̏̕ö̸̝̦̰̗̖̬̦̱͍͇͕͈͎̐͐̍̃̉̓p̸̞̯͖̯̠̓̐̑́̐̓̃̈́̈̓̈́̍̚p̶̛͚̺̩͈̫̟̘͔̮̟̈̊͒̽̊͑̍̀̀͜ę̶̭̙͎̥̱̮͎̞̬̐̉͊̀̎͋̈͝͝ȓ̸̡̛̫̰̰̃͐͑̑̍̊͑̃͘͜͝!̵͖͚̆̒̓̑̉̏̓̚͝
Hello, Bouncy Hopper..
Okay, I don't think that's one of my balls.
Ohh, you tryin' to hide from me? Huh?
Hel- "Hello, Mrs-"
[Scared noises]
Hey!
H̸͚̭͇̫͈̬̣̙̩̳͆ͅę̴̱͈̥͎͕̥͎̤̥͙͇͈͐͂͒̏̑̒̍̚͜͝l̸̳͚͉̱̭̙͔̰͓͖̔͒̏̆̑͐̽̾͆͐̀̚͝͝l̷̛̘̗̇̏͗͒́o̴̡̦͇̗̖̮̖̼̞̼̳̳͗̽̒͂ ̷̢̨̻̲̳̩̠̥̯͉͒̉̿̂̓͗͛̈͆͘͠͝M̶̨̲͔̣̲͔̗̊͆̋̅r̷̢̲̩̙̤͈̝̻͇̰̬̮͖̹̾̅̓͊̊̈́͠ś̵̨̱̮̺͎̼̟̲̘͍̠̦̝̯̱̐̀̉̒̋͊́̕͘͝ ̶̢̠̺͚̦̼̃̐͠Ặ̸̧̥͕̦̣̭̘͕͖͖̬̗́͆́͜͝p̷̡̩̘̬͎̝͔̪̤̙̰͉̜̆̊̌̚͜ͅṕ̶̧̛͔͔̯̫͖͎̹͖͎̪̹̞͔̔̉̏͒̓͒͘l̵̪̞̹̩̹̣̼̘̣͔͉̫̄͋̓͑͐̆͛̊͑̀̈́̕͝ĕ̴̡̺̞̭̫̦̯̬̳̹̯͗̓̔͆̄̓̈!̵̬̫͈̼̠͙̑͒̌̉́̄͂̆̋̒̊ͅͅ
Okay, I'm gonna remember that in my nightmares!
Alright. Eh-
[Grunts]
Damn. Ah, it's so..
I'm so wimpy.
Who's actually barking over there, I don't like that..
Shut up, you! I'm a toddler! Don't you know that I can wreak havoc-
Ough!
what the.. hey!
I fell, apparently!?
Uhh?..
H̶͓̻̺̩͈͕̞̱̹̽̈̈́͛͌̌̿̿̄̑̋̿͒͑e̶̡̗̤̰͚͚̪̥̠͍̲̤͒̃̾͌̾́͝ͅl̵̜̪̦̼̘̾̊́͗̎͆͘͠͠l̷̥̬̯͈̬̺̈́̉̄̓̽̃͆̃̈́͛̿̕ǫ̶̫̺̗̘̘̼̖̫̍̈́̌ͅ ̸̡̘͖͚͕̰̳̇̅̏́͊̋̑́̿͋̾͝͝M̷̤̜̺̜̭̮̩͔̓r̶͓͉̒s̷͈̲̙̜͙̣̪͇̤̖̹̓͜ ̶̡̢̨̹͇̤̹͉̝̯͊͋͆͜P̸̖̓͠ư̷̢̡̲̭̠͇̮̠̇͒͠r̴̡̡̨͈̯̞͓̠̽̑̑̅̾́̌͠p̵̢̛̳̩̹̜̪͈̺̻̼͓͊͗̒͆̍͛̓́̑̕͠ͅͅl̴̢̤̭̱͚͖̞̭͈̮̗̹̍͘ę̶̢̧̰̭͔̥̯͉̞̖̲͐͑͑́̎͊ͅ!̶̢̛̫̳̩̮̞̬̝͎͓͙̥̪͍͑̈͑̈́̉͂̇̈́́͐̚̚͘͜͠
What is happening!? I don't understand!
What is the big thing!?
Is that our pet!?
Is that our version of a dog? Hello..
Uh..
Oh, that's horrible.
Okay, alright, anyway! You take-
You take care of yourself now, you hear? Alright. See you around the bend.
Anything in here? Oooh, I can crawl in!
I didn't even think that was gonna be weird.
Ah. [Mark noises]
Okay, anyway...
[Grunts]
Okay, I've only found three of the bwalls..
Where's the last ball?
H̶̡̪̦͓̅͘͝͠ê̴͍̜̮̣͎̖̼̣̜͈̯̮̤͛̏̉͗́̍́͌̆̾̃͗͜͝l̵̛̬͚̫̓̓̒͒̈̓͒̍̄̓͊̍ͅl̴̡͙̤̮̐͐́̈͂͆̚͘͠͝͝ǫ̵̺͈̲̯͍̪̹̞̖̝͋͂̆̓̎͛̾̿̈́͛̍̕̕ ̷̖̝̗͉͒̎͗̍̑͒͝M̸̛͍̻̯̻̬̟̹̼͖͋͐̿͌̎̈̀̕͘͜ȓ̸̡̰̪̙̂̉̀̽̋͘ ̶̧͆̽L̷̛̜̘̾͂̀̈̽̔̔̊̇͌͘e̷̝̝͐͑̈̊͘̚͜m̷̨̫̤̲͎͍͒̾͋̀̐̋̓͋̈̄̐̿͘͘͝o̶̧̡̦̠̍͐̑̉̏̂͊̐͌̾̍̄̔̕͝ń̸̳̹̲̯̓̀͊͐̐ͅ!̵̪̟̲̗̞͉͎͑̾̓̂́͋͑̌̒̕ͅ
Hello, Mr Lemon!
One..
Twooo..
Threee..
Okay, gotta find the last ball.
Unless you count the bounc-
Uh-
[Gate clanking]
Ah!
Hello! Hi! Welcome! to my backyard! How... are you doing? Good to... see you...
And such as the like, as that? What the hell!?
Hi.
Ohh..
Okay..
Do you have a ball in your hand?
I don't like any of this..
NNnnn, like it even less now oka- aah haahaa.
Game: *mumbling* Hello Mr. Orange
Alrighty then. I'm just gonna -AUUH- give it a big push!
Oh, looks like I gotta finish the job. Hello. Hi. Oh you're so fuzzy- hee- hee.
YOU'RE SO FUZZY! I think I'm gonna die!
Uuhh!
Hello, oh you're Bonbon
Game: *Mumbling* Hello Bonbon!
Okay I got an achievement for that. I'm a big brave boy.
I'm a big brave boy. Where did that ball go?
Ah-yee- oh Mr. Orange what are you doing all the way over here? See you Bonbon!
"Well done looking after your toys time to go inside."- oh is it. Oh, oh is it?
Oh okay!
Alright - *groaning*
Alright...
I'm inside now. I'm very happy about that conundrum.
Alright...mmmmm
Ooh, I'm on the- oh...
Okay, alright, wooden soldier!
Game: Hello Tiny Man!
Mark: Hello Tiny Man?
Game: Hello Draw Man!
Game: [Mommy] Finish playing with your toys, then put them away.
Mark: NO!
"Find all four rubber rings."
What?
Excuse me? Uh oh!
Game: Hello Little Big Mouth!
... woooh
I don't like any of this! I don't like this!
Game: Hello Blue Monster!
What?
Game: Hello Yellow Monster!
Do I get an achievement for like, saying "hi" to everything?
Game: Hello Orange Monster!
Game: Hello Pink Monster!
Game: Hello Green Monster!
Okay - alright! Why am I doing this? Why? Why am I doing this?
Game: Hello Peewee!
Hello "Peewee". Oohh! Peewee not do so good!
Bye Peewee! Ok, I found a doughnut.
Game: Hello Blue Ring!
All right, found a blue ring mom. Are you proud of me yet, mom?
Mom, I found a... I can't move. I'm very tired. I can -UUH!
K -Where do I put this?
Do I put it over... D-Do I put it over here? Uuh. No? Okay. Uh wh-?
Nah, it won't let me. Okay. Ashtray, monsters... doughnut!
Game: Hello Green Ring!
Uhh. Why are you saying it so slow and weird like that?
*Grunts*
Uh, one!
Game: Hello Tiny Man!
Hello "Tiny Man"! Uh, TWOO!
Game: Hello Yellow Face!
Hello "Yellow Face"!
I'm such a good - good kid.
Game: Hello Purple Ring!
Purple RAAAANG!!
Game: Hello Red Ring!
RED RAAAAng!!
Redrum! Redrum! Redrum!
Mom! Mom, redrum!
Mom, I'm screaming "redrum" again. Come on, shouldn't you be at least concerned about my safety?
Do I need to put the rest of my toys away?
Uh! No, missed. Hey! Get in there Mr.Wiggle Worm! Uh oh.
Game: Hello Pink Monster!
OOOH!!
The monster blocks! Aaaahuuh!
I'm such a good, diligent little brat! I put away everything. Look at me go. What..?
Game: Hello Yellow Digger!
Booah! Okay, that was scary. You just- I don't know why you did that. Okay, alright then. Hello Wobbly Dog.
Oh, there you are! I know I saw ya.
Oh HUH! Wayayyayaa AH HEY Hi!
Okay, hi - hi, how's it going - hi. Hello, hi!
Okay. Hi Bon-
What do you got there Bonbon? You got- you got tiny people?
Game: Hello Bonbon!
HELLO Bonbon!
Oh Heh ne-
Why - I don't like this. I don't want to play with your "tiny man" Bonbon. I just- you know..
Alright, whatever...
Game: Hello Tiny Man!
Hello "Tiny man"
*Grunts*
So... Strong I am
Oh, Bonbon you are- you are just a world a concern right now.
Did I throw that tiny man up there? Because if I did I might be boned.
Three.
Where is the last tiny person? He's one of the first people I found.
So, uh...
Bonbon do you have something in your hand? Bonbon! Bonbon, please!
Game: [Mummy] Come on, time to tidy up.
Oh, Bonbon...
Well, thank you. Ah goddamn- I just- I was about to! Mom! I was gonna!
Darkness?
Game: [Mummy] Open your eyes...
Mark: I don't wanna
Game: [Mummy] Happy Birthday, love!
Aaayye!
*forced blowing*
Yeah I do-
*"sneezes"*
I got it!
Game: [Mummy] Now, a big slice for you and...
Is it Bonbon? It might be Bonbon.
Game: [Mummy] I suppose that would be your father.
Ehh, I don't know. How would I know?
Game: [Mummy] Back in a minute.
I got a bad feeling about this~
Can I open my godda-
WOAHH!!! HI BONBON!!!
Hello!
Welcome to... my birthday, apparently. Ah look at that.
Hello Mr.Chatterbox
My- My vision seems to be an extra bit drawn towards something on this- goodbye then - oh wow! Okay.
Cake, you want cake?
Bonbon!
You- I'm trying to-
Woah!
That's some disgusting drool.
Bonbon I got a bad feeling about- ohhh...
Don't look at me like that.
You want more Bonbon? Bonbon Bonbon?
Bonbon!
You want-
More? Huh?
Woah! Good gah-
Okay! Alright! Very eager.
No Bonbon!
Bonbon no!
Noo Bonbon!
Oh boy uh-
No!
Noooo!
No Bonbon!
Bonbon, Bonbon you got a problem-
*Bonbon slams table*
Hey! Whoa whoa! Easy there, easy!
No no no!
Hey. Okay, alright, you know what, maybe. Maybe it might be a good idea- How about no? How about... No!
No!
Oh it's bad idea, oh it's a bad idea, it's a bad idea.
Can you tell that was a bad idea?
Oh boy, okay. Alright.
Okay, alright. There you go Bonbon. You happy?
You better be happy.
No no no! NOOO!! BON BON!!
No!
No- eh -no no no no no!
Okay. Alright. I guess I got gotta. Alright, let's rip that off of there.
Ay yoy.
Don't worry I'm gonna get the- I'll go get the next one. You ready? Yeah, hungry baby!
Goodness gracious.
I can't give you any more, it's out of reach. Bonbon get it for yourself.
Bonbon, what do you want from me? I literally can't!
Bonbon! What- I-
Mr. Chatterbox. Here you go, you want Mr. Chatterbox?
Skidaddle! Uuh, alright. Okay.
I can't- how can- I can't- uh...
Is it the knife? I don't know.
Got- go away!
Okay! Alright! That's no good...
Oooouuhh!
Mom! We got a- buh
Rodent problem! It's very -uh...large...problematic...
Game: [Daddy] Once upon a time there was an old miller who had two children who were twins.
The boy twin was named Hans, and he was very greedy. The girl twin was named Hilda and, she was very lazy.
Hans and Hilda had no mother, because she died whilst giving birth to their third sibling, named Engel,
who had been sent away to live with the gypsies.
Mark: There's a great story dad.
Game: [Daddy] Hans and Hilda were never allowed out of the mill, even when the miller went away to the market.
One day, Hans was especially greedy and Hilda was especially lazy,
and the old miller wept with anger as he locked them in the cellar to teach them to be good.
"Let us try to escape, and live with the gypsies" said Hans, and Hilda agreed.
While they were looking for a way out, a Big Brown Rat came out from behind the log pile.
"I will help you to escape and show you the way the gypsies' camp," said the Big Brown Rat,
"if you bring me all of your father's grain."
So Hans and Hilda waited until their father let them out.
And the next day, when the miller went to the market and left the children locked inside the mill, they carried all the grin down to the cellar.
The Big brown Rat gobbled up all the grain until there was none left, and then, went to sleep behind the log pile.
When the miller came home and found out, he declared that he was ruined and that they would all starve to death,
and he locked the children in the cellar, and wept with fear as he turned the key.
The Big Brown Rat was waiting.
" I will only help the boy-child to escape and show him the way to the gypsies' camp," said the Big Brown Rat.
"because the girl-child must stay behind and be my wife."
"Come back once you've organized the wedding."
"Once I've escaped, I find our brother Engel and lead him back to rescue you," whispered Hans to Hilda.                    Mark: wuhhhhHH
Game: [Daddy] So, Hans and Hilda waited until their father let them out.
The next, day, when the miller was out bartering for new grain,
they, made the trail of bread crumbs all round the mill and into the cellar, to show the wedding guests where to go.
They took the most important pages out of the hymnal, so that the priest would have the right words to say,
Then they stole the miller's best Sunday jacket, and took in the shoulders so that it would fit Hans,
and they stole their mother's wedding dress and took up the hem so that it would fit Hilda.
Then she put it on and she looked lovely,
but when the miller returned from the market and saw them dressed up in wedding clothes, he wept with shame as he beat them, and threw them both into the cellar once more.
The wedding guests were already assembled.
There were mice and voles and stoats in the congregation.
The choir was made up of crows, who were already singing.
The registrar was a big fat spider, with spectacles on,
And the priest was a long, grey weasel, who was busy rehearsing the right words from the hymnal.
Hans walked Hilda down the isle, and the Big Brown Rat was waiting.
The weasel said, "Do you accept this offered paw in binding and inescapable holy matrimony, Hilda Girl-Child?"
Hilda looked at Hans, who nodded as if to remind her that he would rescue her.
"I do," said Hilda.
The weasel said, "Do you take this innocent young hand for your very, own, Engel Monstrous Rat-Baby?"
"I do," said the Big Brown Rat, before anyone could interrupt.
"Then-I-now pronounce-you-man-and-wife," squeaked the weasel as quickly as he could, and in a flash all of the wedding party scattered, and Hans and Hilda were left alone with the Big Brown Rat.
"I don't understand," said Hans.
The Big Brown Rat pushed Hans through a secret tunnel that led down to the river bank, and Hans escaped and ran off and became a beggar boy.
Of course, he never found his brother Engel, and never rescued Hilda.
The miller finally hung himself, but nobody minded,
and Hilda died whilst giving birth to a beautiful litter of thirteen baby rats,
Mark: W-WHAT?!?!
Game: [Daddy] who grew fat in the miller's grain.
and lived happily ever after.
Mark: THAT'S NOT A GOOD STORY AT ALL DAD!!!
Let me just lay my sweet baby addressed! What the hecking hell!?
Okay, why, not this? Okay, alright, why, not this?
Whatever this is. I am so perturbed.
Hello, what are you?
Game: Hello Lightbug!
Hello, Lightbug. Okay, we're gonna go over this way now. A-da-that is not a good story!
Where am I? Why am I in here?
Wha-
Ah...
Okay...
I feel like that story might have been- whoa, all right then. Low gravity I suppose. That's also an option.
Ah- this is terrible. You ever look around and you're like, "oh yeah- this is- is-"
OOOOOHHhhhh!!!
Nooo, Wobbly Dog!!
What did you do?
Well...
Game: Hello Koalalama!
Okay...
Game: Hello Wobbly Dog!
You know what? I'm just gonna just stop saying hello to everybody, 'cause I think that's my main problem here.
Okay! Well I didn't want to go that way anyway, so- what are you doing tiny lady?
Game: Hello Tiny Lady!
Okay! Alrighty then.
Anytime, you can...you can drop that. That'd be nice. Or not... I don't know why I'm in here...
Okay. Alrighty then.
Wait a minute!!!
Something's different!! Something- something different!!! Can't- oh I can't place, my eyes upon it.
Mmm okay, alright, well this is fun.
Okay. You know what? That's great. That's great. Ah hello!
Wobbly dog? You're...all better!
Or something...
Game: Hello Wobbly Dog!
Sure thing. Okay, alright you go that way! See ya!
Hopefully, see ya never, but alright. What in the hell is going on here?
This might be one of the weirdest- yeah oh. I thought that was Bonbon. This might be one of the weirdest
games I've played in recent history.
Alrighty then.
Well! Hmmm...
Ooooohhh...Bonbon?
Whoa! Aye I don't have any cake for you okay?!
This guy- I'm trying to escape!
I'm very slow. Oh... What in the heck?
Ah that's...whoa!
Okay! Alright! Skildoodally do~
I'm very slow at this! Hi! Okay hi!
Ah...
Bonbon there's- there's really no need for any of this.
Bonbon....
I'm trying! I'm trying to hide!
Oh look, Lightbug...
Alright... Hey, Bonbon I'm just gonna come out
and say it, I know it's an unpopular opinion here.
I know that everyone's gonna roast me in the comments, but I just don't like
Bonbon i'm gonna! I'onna- I'onna just say that out lot- I just don't like him.
Bonbons a bit of a dick. Okay!!
Hmm...
Hmm, okay, that's that's not good.
Whoa! whoa! Ah- you got short stubby arms! No I'm- why am I going towards it?!
Never been more confused about a game in my life!
Borat! But hey, that's the perspective of a child I suppose. So, anyway that, was Bonbon that was a-
That was good! I mean honestly, it was good in that it engrossed me. Controls were a
little wonky because it's an indie game and it's a little like-
unpolished, but still, like I was engrossed the whole time. I wanted to know what the hell was going on. It was so weird having
Bonbon just there from the very get-go.
Standing there, and you just stumble upon the Bonbon. So, either way, that was really fun. Hope
you guy, enjoyed it. I'll leave a link to the game in the description below, let me know
what you thought down in the comments down there.
Thanks again, and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye - bye!